knows how to make you think you're the
best thing but i know what happens next
girl the two cma nominations
first of all female artist of the year
and album of the year
that has to like
be up there with some of the greatest
news you've ever received
to be nominated as the only female for
album of the year
on an album that when i started writing
i thought i was going to die
yeah and i was so lost and so broken in
every way losing my producer losing my
marriage
all i can see
through that is like the phoenix rising
from the ashes and just like coming out
with like a fiddle and just
exploded
[Music]
all that emotion caught the attention of
the one and only dolly parton who
surprised carly with an invitation to
join the grand ole opry
it's a full circle moment for the 31
year old who used to sing at dollywood
as a teenager there has to be a part of
you that feels that every time you see
dolly that is one step closer that you
are going to get to being on a song with
darling
that people are always like who would
you like to collaborate with next i'm
like dolly i would love to sing with
dolly so we're getting closer we'll see
but for now the singer is in good
company touring with grammy winners lady
a and which one is the cleanest on tour
and which one is not hillary has
children so i feel like she's probably
got a lot going on i would say dave
there's just something about dave that
feels like he was just so put together
in every way and then just i love you
charles so much but i bet you're the
messy one you're like
[Music]